hugely important to me to maintain a
certain energy you've got to take a shot
you have to live at the edge of your
capabilities you gotta live where you're
almost certain you're gonna fail choose
actions that are in your own best
interest every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest need
motivation
what's top 10 with believe nation what's
that belief nation it's Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent add something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being a great
student in school but not wanting to go
to college because he wanted to rap to
now becoming one of the leading men and
most successful stars in Hollywood he's
Will Smith and here's my take on his top
ten rooms a success vol 4
enjoy
[Music]
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one find your purpose finding
your purpose like that's a that's a
that's a big one just keep trying stuff
just keep trying you got a key keep
going and in terms of finding purpose it
was helpful for me to realize that just
because everybody at Philly believed you
know one thing in one set of ideas and
everybody in Philly was in a certain
paradigm as soon as I got out of the
city and out of the country I realized
there were people that didn't give a
damn about stuff that was the most
important thing in the world
try experiment me travel that was a big
part for me and that's a lot of what
you're gonna sing on my youtube channel
to like travel is huge
rule number two maintain infectious
energy what you just told Mike this we
just bought you not just I it's hugely
important to me to maintain a certain
energy it's a it's it's healing it's
loving its kind and I've learned really
young that my energy was infectious
right so when you know I come into the
studio when I long after I leave the
energy that I bring is still gonna be
here and then people are gonna take it
home and they're gonna affect their
families with it so you know for me it's
hugely important to maintain just a
positive loving energy just Rosie's your
wife's grateful yeah yeah I'm really
happy it's funny I worked with G I
worked with Gene Hackman and we had a
thing every morning because Gene Hackman
wasn't a morning person and he said this
is what I do anymore
you know so every morning I would say I
would say day good-morning mr. Hakman do
ya I don't say how you doing will I say
hey man I'm just happy to be here he
would say no you're lucky to be here
every morning but it became my way of
like just you know getting it getting it
up and getting it going it's just I love
it
rule number three my personal favorite
fail forward I love this one fail early
fail often fail forward you know it's
always a little bit frustrating to me
when people have a negative relationship
with failure failure is a massive part
of being able to be successful you have
to get comfortable with failure yet you
have to actually seek failure failure is
where all of the lessons are you know
when you go to the gym and you work out
you're actually seeking failure you want
to take your muscles to the point where
you get to failure because that's where
the the adaptation is that's where
growth is successful people who fail a
lot they fail a whole lot more than they
succeed but they extract the lessons
from the failure and they use that the
the energy and they use the wisdom to
come around to the next phase of success
you got to take a shot you have to live
at the edge of your capabilities you got
to live where you're almost certain
you're gonna fail that's the reason for
a practice practice is controlled
failure you're getting to your limit
getting to your limit getting to your
limit you can't lift that you can't do
that you until you get to the point that
all of a sudden your body makes the
adjustment and then you can do it
failure actually helps you to recognize
the areas where you need to evolve so
fail early fail often fail forward rule
number four dedicate your life to your
dream I think was 94 something like that
they were open to Planet Hollywood I
found myself in a room with Arnold
Schwarzenegger Bruce Willis and sly and
I was like oh my god I got these three
guys in there
and I was like okay I want to be the
biggest movie star in the world and I
need you guys to tell me how to do it
and Arnold Schwarzenegger he said he
said if your movie is only big in
America it doesn't matter you'll be a
movie star only when you're a movie star
in every country in the world you have
to travel you have to go you have to
meet the people thanks for the tip fax
son fax that became the way that I
started looking at movies I wanted to be
in every country in the world in that
part of my career I refused to do
anything that wasn't in the best
interest of the goal I had set for
myself and there's probably a 12 year
period of my life where I did take a
trainee I have a drink where I didn't go
out in the weekends I was so set on my
goal it created a serious circle of
protection and an elevation because I
refuse to do anything that wasn't in my
best interest it's hugely important that
if you have a dream
that you have to dedicate your life to
it and there at every hour of every day
it has to be dedicated to bring it into
fruition the things that you dream about
rule number five seek those who fan your
flames I just saw this Rumi quote that I
love set your life on fire and seek
those who fan your flames the Phillie
translation of that is don't be hanging
with no Jang casts Joker's that don't
help you shine the prerequisite for
spending time with any person is that
they nourish and inspire you
they feed your flame look at your last
five text messages are those people
feeding your flames or dousing your fire
put your phone down for just a second
and look around look to the people
around you are those people throwing
logs on your fire or they pissing on it
the people that you spend time with are
going to make or break your dreams
everybody don't deserve to be around you
you got to defend your light
with your life so who are the people in
your life that are fanning your flames
shout them out tag on below rule number
six do everything you originally settled
off as a rapper so I was wondering you
know it's been tuned over ten years
since your last album experimenting in
the studio yeah I can explore in like
new sounds like the new wave of hip hop
are you releasing like planning on
releasing any new music so yes so I just
actually just haven't been probably 30
days on on Instagram and so you can
follow me at and I just launched a
YouTube channel and they didn't realize
how great social media was for the short
form content so I have all of these
ideas I have all of these songs I have
all of these skits I have all of these
things that didn't think I'd ever get
around to putting out that I'll be doing
on my social media so I'll definitely be
putting out records I'll definitely be
doing skits and I'll definitely be
creating content that has been bubbling
in me for years rule number seven decide
to inspire people I went to Catholic
school up to eighth grade with all white
kids and probably two or three black
kids but if you know predominantly white
school and then I went to my
neighborhood high school in ninth grade
that was 99% black kids so the first day
that I walk in to ninth grade I walked
into the lunchroom and you know it's
like 500 kids and for to this day I
don't know why I did this I'm sure it
was because I was I was nervous and you
know I got that I have a thing with fear
I don't like being scared so I'm sure I
was I walked in I looked around and I
said excuse me can I have your attention
can I have your attention please
he's here he's here right now thank you
thank you I think we've got a looking
and there was just one dude and he
sitting there and he looked up to me he
said man don't know my kibble that you
here right and I said hey just give me
ten minutes your girl going care right
and he was like and you got to watch
that not that not is not a good night he
was like
and I was like okay so I went some
walking up the steps we're out of the
lunch room and I forgot about it
so we're gone and I'm walking up the
steps and he had taken one of those
combination locks and he put the lock in
the palm of his hand and put his put the
the loop around his knuckle and he was
holding the lock in his hand and as I
was walking up the steps he cracked me
in the side of my head with the lot and
I went down I was out I don't remember
nothing I still got the lump on my head
you can't see it because they over here
but I stood like this still alone so I
remember I fell down and I hit my mouth
on the steps all of that stuff you know
so I went up so I'm in the principal's
office all of that the police come and I
got the ice on my lips and I'm sitting
in the principal's office and my father
comes in he sees me and you know I'm
telling the story now the police are
there and I remember I saw this kid they
put him in handcuffs and took him out of
the school and I'm looking sitting in
the principal's office and I'm watching
the police take him out and put him in
the back of a police car and I just
couldn't believe it had escalated to a
kid being removed from from school and I
was laying in my bed that night
and I was just feeling like Shh
and I had the recognition that I had
caused this kid to throw his life away
right and he was kicked out of school
and I never knew what happened to him
but I have a sense that it didn't go
well
beyond there and I felt a deep sense of
regret and a deep sense that I had
caused an emotion in a person that made
them do that and that that feeling of
regret turned into a sort of a fear of
how much power I had and I was like
everything I say and do has that kind of
effect on other human beings and in that
moment I decided that I would never walk
into a room and do anything other than
inspire and uplift and enlighten people
and help people to be the greater
versions of themselves and I would never
do anything that would cause people to
or to rile up the darkest dirtiest parts
of people I only wanted to enliven and
enlighten and inspire and I remember
laying in my bed that night and I made
that promise to myself and I made that
promise to God and it's something that
has completely shaped how I approach
people how I approach moments how I walk
into rooms how I deal with every human
being on this earth
rule number eight develop
self-discipline
so dude screamed to me the other night a
will I wanna be active man I will be
active just like you you know usually
people say stuff to me like that I'm
like yeah man
you do is give them an encouraging word
but I was just sitting here thinking and
it dawned on me 99% of people that say
stuff like that are not willing to do
what it takes to make their dreams come
true the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and that's just real at the
center of bringing any dream into
fruition is self-discipline you know
something something as simple as food
and eating it's not about your body as
much as it is about your mind it's
getting command of your mind to be able
to choose actions that are in your own
best interest every day we are choosing
[ __ ] that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you in the
world's trying to hold you down so you
gonna kick yourself in the balls so you
will stop yourself from getting what you
dream self-discipline is the center of
all material success you cannot win the
war against the world if you can't win
the war against your own mind rule
number nine take responsibility I was
just having a debate with a friend of
mine and we got stuck on the difference
between fault
and responsibility she kept talking
about how something was somebody's fault
somebody's fault
and I was like it really don't matter
whose fault it is that something is
broken if it's your responsibility to
fix it for example is it's not
somebody's fault if their father was an
abusive alcoholic but it's for damn sure
their responsibility to figure out how
they're gonna do with those traumas and
try to make a life out of it it's not
your fault if your partner cheated and
ruined your marriage but it is for damn
sure
your responsibility to figure out how to
take that pain and how to overcome that
and build a happy life for yourself
fault and responsibility do not go
together it sucks but they don't when
something is somebody's fault we want
them to
suffer we want them punished we want
them to pay and we want it to be their
responsibility to fix it but that's
that's not how it works especially when
it's your heart your heart your life
your happiness is your responsibility
and your responsibility alone as long as
we're pointing the finger and and stuck
in whose fault
something is we're jammed and trapped
into victim mode when you're in victim
mode you are stuck in suffering the road
to power is in taking responsibility
your heart your life your happiness is
your responsibility and your
responsibility alone and rule number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is have fun which is gonna ask us
each to name three things three types of
like cars or something and we'll have
five seconds to name three things and
then hit that to see how much time is
left on the clock okay all right if you
do it you get a point if time runs out
you get no points at all five seconds
goes very very fast okay I shall go
first you shall go first okay okay Ellen
name three things you do in a car you
drive you park and you say hello to
people
see I see now we need some like judges
are you job you say how do you wink you
will name three things you should never
do in a car never drink smoke three
words you use a lot love baby and be
kind I'm gonna give you that one cuz
that's the right answer
okay we'll name your three favorite
songs to sing in the shower in the
shower the dream girls
I'm telling you Whitney Houston's
died yeah but that's it's like the end I
am tan
Oh
[Applause]
you're the best man there's no way I can
ever go no no no no that's my song
[Applause]
[Music]
now I've got a really special Will Smith
bonus clip I think you're gonna enjoy
around how to be still but before that I
want to know what did you learn from
this video will has so many great
messages what did you take from this
that you're going to apply somehow to
your life or your business starting
today leave it down in the comments
below when you write it down you're much
more likely to actually take that action
so write it in the comments thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
something that came in Islands just got
finished doing a couple days of work and
you knows I'm in the room I'm finally by
myself as quiet as no people around I'm
chilling and I'm like me enough trying
to figure out something to do so you
know I figured I had let me go turn the
news on and then it dawned on me it was
like but the news agitates me it's
disruptive I get aggravated and I was
like nah and then I felt this crazy urge
like I couldn't stop myself from going
to turn the news on and I was like oh
[ __ ] and I realized my mind was seeking
disturbance but now it's too peaceful I
need I need to be disrupted and and
aggravated and then I realized like we
actually have to cultivate a taste for
peace we're actually addicted to things
that agitate and aggravate us you know
you're like damn every time I see this
person we argue I'm just I don't I don't
want to argue with this food we'll stop
what happens is we actually get addicted
to the argument we're addicted to the
aggravation addicted to the agitation I
just really made a decision to myself
today just sitting here in the Cayman
Islands that I'm gonna be quiet I'm
gonna be still and I'm gonna be alone I
mean right after you listen to my ig
story and right after you you follow me
then then put it down and just just
still be alone and quiet and still y'all
one was long media the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]